so it looks like a wall of text but if
we step through this together slowly
it's not confusing stuff we know all
this language so let's have a look
question 4 in 2d let's just start from
the top of the question it says find the
y coordinate of the point a on this
curve here it is I've written it down
and you might like to do the same where
x equals R 1/2 okay so let's just make
sure we get our heads straight this
curve here right it's going to be an
exponential curve right and every x
value has a y value along with it it's a
function not a relation we want the
particular Y value when x equals I think
it's as 1/2 right so here's exactly how
I'd like you to set it out write your
original function equation there so that
we can refer to it easily rather than
look at the you know I'm sure I'm not
the only person who's like start of a
question and it looked at the wrong line
for an equation and then like wait why
am I answers all wrong because you look
at the wrong actual function so write
this down so you've got it right there
above your your eye line and then say
when x equals 1/2 okay now what I'm
searching for is a Y value so I'm going
to substitute this back into the
original function yeah that makes sense
so let's go ahead and do that when x
equals 1/2 y equals and I'm just going
to do a straight substitution no changes
or anything like that
e to the power of 2 x 1/2 minus 1 now we
know what to multiply by 1/2 is but I'm
doing this step really explicitly so I
don't screw up my substitution and so if
I do it's really easy to see where I
went wrong ok
all right let's let's have a go so I've
now got e to the power of what's gonna
happen up here 2 times 1/2 is 1 1 take
away 1 is 0 so that's that now I happen
to know and I hope you do is what what e
to the power of 0 is but I think it's
probably a bridge too far to skip right
to that straight away I want this line
in here is a sort of scaffold for my
thinking and then I evaluate its equal
to 1 fantastic at this point have I got
my answer more or less but I would
probably like to write it down a little
neater than that they've talked in the
question about some point a the point a
has this x value and this Y value so
I'm gonna say they're for a and I'm
gonna write it the way that I would
write a point there's the first question
okay Part B moves on and this is where
the calculus starts to kick in it says
find the derivative of that function and
ensure that the grain of the tangent at
a is this okay so that's that's a lot to
take in
let's just do one step at a time they
want us to find the derivative so Part B
we've got Y I've written up there so I'm
gonna write dy on DX I'm quick note by
the way you remember how I tell you
about all that sort of wrong notation
before don't talk about dy on DX
unless your question has a Y right if
it's got f of X then use that notation
if they haven't labeled it if there's
just giving you some function like this
and you want to talk about its
derivative then give it a name and then
you can start talking say it again we'll
come to that's a really good question
its first said find the derivative of
that so we want to know about it
without regard to any X values we want
it for all X values so let's just we've
been doing this for last
you know hour or so let's get the
derivative here's the original function
what's the inside function 2x minus 1 so
it's derivative is 2 that's just the
inside part and then I move on to the
rest of it so the outside function is e
to the power of some stuff what happens
when we differentiate e to the power of
some stuff yeah nothing happens to it
it's e to the power of that stuff there
we go there's my derivative
and now strange question it says show
that the gradient of the tangent at a is
2 so in other words this will give me
the gradient if I substitute in an
appropriate x value and the x value that
i want in this case is 1/2 what i got
from the previous part so again i'm
gonna set that out right i'm gonna say
when x equals 1/2 right i'm now gonna
evaluate my gradient it will give me a
sorry I'm gonna value out my derivative
which will give me a gradient yes it
should I hope DUI and DX let's go ahead
and again do that substitution step so
I've got 2 e to the to 1/2 minus 1 that
feels familiar doesn't it it's the same
function I was dealing with earlier so
just like before I'm going to get to
each the naught which is two and that's
what I was supposed to guess so I
generally when they give me some kind of
result they're like hey prove this thing
right
I generally end by saying yeah that's
the thing that you required me to find
to as you request it okay
this puppet have we answered the
question you're happy with that I will
just put one additional thing on which
may or may not be helpful but I think
it's sort of helpful in terms of the
question it's show that the gradient of
the tangent at a that's gee that's a
long phrase right we have a usual letter
that we use to indicate gradient which
letter do we usually use em right so I'm
gonna say M this is a gradient a
specific place a day so I'm gonna say M
and I usually use a little subscript
little a down the bottom there so this
is a way of saying the gradient at that
point a is two because that's how I
calculate it alright Part C here's where
we're going to tie this up in a bow so
this is what's called an application of
differentiation we differentiate it and
we can apply that knowledge to find you
can see in Part C the equation of a
tangent so a tangent is a straight line
that just touches right it just touches
this graph which I'm just gonna eyeball
for you now it's gonna look something
like this 1/2 comma 1 right so what I'm
trying to find is the equation of the
tangent at that spot which I guess will
look something like that right that's
what the line I'm trying to find what
its equation is okay now I already know
a point that goes through it and I've
also just in Part B fan of the gradient
at that point so how do I combine that
to get the equation of the line point
great form thank you very much can we
recite together what point gradient form
of a straight line is I'll give you a
clue star to the Y very good M X minus
x1 fantastic so there's point gradient
form if you want to maybe put for
yourself a little reminder because this
is something we're calling on from our
coordinate geometry knowledge
this is point granite form of a straight
line and all I need to do is take all
the information I dealt in the earlier
parts of the question and appropriately
substitute them in okay so y minus what
is y1 it's one that's what I got from
pot a okay the M is now what I got in
the previous part puppies so I'll put in
two okay there we go
I've done all the substitution just have
a quick look at the question it says
hence find the equation of the tangent a
it didn't say in any particular form but
I surely I can simplify this right what
might be the first thing you do yeah
this guy we can simplify by expanding so
I'll write 2x minus 1 thank you can we
collect all that constant terms together
where would you have to put them in a
little basket will do okay I'm gonna put
them in this basket which adds them
together I'm going to add 1 to both
sides so you hear that you're gonna get
y equals careful I'm adding 1 to both
sides right plus 1 cancels plus 1 also
cancels so here's my little basket okay
now having a look at this does this
match roughly what I expected I mean I
bought this so you can see I don't quite
go through the origin but it matches
like I'm increasing it's gonna go
roughly through that point so I think
I'm okay I'm in the ballpark right am I
done with the question yet ready
carefully okay I've got to show it that
passes through it's actually not a zero
it's an iron which means what is the Oh
meaning court in geometry that's the
origin thank you so it's zero zero how
do you take a line and prove that it
goes through somewhere what would you do
um you could graph it you certainly
could graph it I don't take a really
long time though like it seems like an
excessive way to go about this I could
Shawn what do you think
chamber one something mean that if y is
equal to the point we chose yeah yeah
fantastic so let me just make sure to
rehearse that Chantal me forgotten right
we know where the origin is it's zero
zero x equals zero and y equals zero
should be able to take both of those pop
them in here and it should satisfy this
equation so let's go ahead and do that
when x equals zero I'm going to do the
substitution into this straight line y
is going to be two times zero
I know that it's comically like trivial
to say it like I know what two times
zero is right the reason why I'm
including this line and then saying zero
is the question says hey prove it prove
that that should be y equals zero and so
if I just said x equals zero y equals
zero you're not really kind of proving
anything you're just stating what the
question says right so even though this
seems like a really simple thing to put
I think it's helpful because it shows
where I've put it into does that make
sense
zero zero zero zero satisfies this is
probably my final line y equals 2x so it
passes through the origin could I put
what through the point variable
oh okay so I could put zero zero into
here and also need the gradient as well
which is to I think you could but it'd
be very roundabout way of doing it I
think this is probably the most
straightforward it's like a whole one
two or three lines two and a half lines
really okay so now I have any questions